in a few short years the keanu
reeves-led john wick franchise has grown
into one of the most popular and
recognizable film series in the world
while it often receives the bulk of its
praise for its visual presentation and
seamless fight sequences
it doesn't get nearly enough credit for
its world building the lore behind the
john wick universe and the characters
that inhabit it are incredibly
interesting to dive into
chief among these entities is the
mysterious and disheveled bowery king
brought to life by the legendary
lawrence fishburne
first introduced in john wick chapter 2
the bowery king presents himself as
nothing more than a homeless man with
an affinity for pigeons this description
however hardly scratches the surface of
who he really
is yes killing someone who has a seat at
the high
table does create a problem but it's
your problem baby
in john wick chapter 2 after santino
d'antonio puts a 7 million
bounty on john wick's head he's on the
run from every able-bodied assassin in
the world
with no supplies and a dwindling chance
of survival he turns to the bowery king
for assistance
who hesitantly supplies him with a
handgun and only seven rounds
one for each million during their
meeting they briefly touch on their
shared history and how wick's past
change of heart led to the king's
unofficial coordination
years before the events of the john wick
films the man who would become the
bowery king was the titular assassin's
target
the two faced off and wick came out the
victor but elected not to finish his
opponent off
instead leaving him wounded this defeat
drove the bowery king to quietly climb
the ladder in the criminal underworld
eventually taking hold of his
headquarters called the soup kitchen
and recruiting new york city's
panhandlers and street beggars to his
cause
even though his operation is largely
undercover the bowery king's system of
spies and informants
didn't go unnoticed at the high table
the two groups began collaborating as
soon as the soup kitchen became the
epicenter of the bowery kings network
with the king offering up its services
in exchange for the high tables
resources
although the likes of winston and sophia
ran their respective continental hotels
under high table jurisdiction
the king did things a bit differently
out of his own hubris and self-interest
screenwriter derek colstad spoke to
inverse and elaborated on how the bowery
king's operation
tends to rub the high table the wrong
way he said we find out the assassin's
world is split between those who operate
under certain guidelines and those who
don't
the bowery king never pledged any honest
fealty to the high table and continued
to run fairly independently from them
much to their dismay no there will be no
replacement for me on the throne
because i am the throne baby i am the
ballerina this is why they didn't mind
sending assassins to his doorstep to
wipe out his people and maim him for
aiding john wick
even before he was labeled excommunicado
suffice to say their mutual arrangement
has come to its conclusion for the time
being
however the bowery king seems like he'll
still play a major role in the franchise
there are a handful of john wick fans
who've cooked up some very interesting
theories about what could be coming in
future installments
one of the most popular subsets of them
connects the john wick universe to that
of the matrix which also starred keanu
reeves and lawrence fishburne
as one would imagine a theory involving
the matrix tends to get a bit meta the
deeper the rabbit hole goes
the bare bones of it are that john
wick's adventures are all part of a
computer simulation that neo is
experiencing inside the world of the
matrix
and the bowery king is a construct of
fishburn's character from the matrix
morpheus
trying to awaken neo to fight their
oppressors
it's a lot you take the red pill
you stay in wonderland and i show you
how deep the rabbit hole goes
fan theories aside fish burn turned out
to be an excellent addition to the cast
of john wick and the barry king
character fit perfectly into the films
fishburn's casting is actually based on
the friendship and respect that he and
reeves have for one another as fish burn
tells it in an interview on the film is
now youtube channel
fishburn said he actually spoke with
reeves after seeing the first john wick
film and told him he'd love to be a part
of the sequel
this prompted reeves to put in a good
word for his friend with the directors
and the rest is history check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one